un puente colgante tiene dos pilares que
se levantan 500 metros desde el camino y
están conectados por cables que cuelgan
en forma de una parábola que se puede
representar porque es igual a esta
expresión que tenemos aquí donde x y ya
se miden dos metros y x es la distancia
desde el pilar izquierdo hasta el pilar
derecho la pregunta es cuál es la
distancia entre estos dos pilares y
bueno para resolver este problema creo
que sería bastante bueno hacer una
gráfica o hacer un dibujo de qué es lo
que está pasando en este problema así
que para esto lo primero que quiero que
nos toquemos es en el pilar izquierdo
este va a ser mi pilar izquierdo y bueno
para no meternos en problemas voy a
decir que aquí es x igual a cero es
decir estamos aquí en el origen y por lo
tanto esté mejor va a ser el cero y este
va a ser mi eje de las x este de aquí y
por cierto dice que lo que estamos
buscando es la distancia entre este
pilar izquierdo y el pilar derecho que
voy a dibujar
aquí este va a ser mi pilar derecho y si
te das cuenta
estamos en el eje de las equis así que
déjenme pintar una vez el eje de las x
porque de hecho es lo que nos preguntan
es cuál es la distancia entre estos dos
pilares así que déjame poner aquí mi eje
de las x va a ser justo este que estoy
dibujando aquí esto es por una parte y
por otra parte quiero que veas que lo
que queremos es la distancia entre estos
dos pilares que puede ser de 1000 metros
o un metro y que estén aquí pegadas la
una de la otra pero lo que me importa
saber a qué distancia están estos dos
pilares estas dos torres y ahora voy a
pensar en el eje de las 10 donde el eje
de las yes lo que representa es la
altura la altura vista de una forma
general y además el problema me dice
algo muy importante estos dos pilares
están conectados de punta a punta por
unos cables que forman una parábola
desde la punta del pilar izquierdo hasta
la punta del pilar derecho están
conectados por unos cables los cuales
tienen la forma de una parábola y es que
este es el dato más importante que nos
dice el problema y bueno déjame dibujar
una mejor parábola si estamos no está es
una peor parábola una mejor parábola si
estamos hablando de parábolas porque
aquí hay varias formas de resolver este
problema pero para mí la forma más
importante y la más lógica es fijarme en
el vértice de esta parábola porque el
vértice de esta parábola es justo el
punto medio o la mitad que hay entre
estos dos pilares si yo encuentro cuánto
vale el valor de x aquí pues este valor
de x va a estar a la mitad de la
distancia entre estos dos pilares o
dicho otra manera se encuentra que el
valor de x lo multiplicó por 2 encuentra
la distancia entre estos dos pilares y
esto es porque estos cables que forman
la parábola están conectados desde las
dos puntas de estos pilares aquí está la
clave de este problema porque yo sé que
la ecuación es igual a 1 entre este
número t que tengo aquí que multiplica a
su vez x menos 2000
elevado al cuadrado más 8 y bueno cuando
esta función se hace mínima y esta
función se hace mínima cuando date
cuenta de esto x menos 2100 al cuadrado
y siempre es mayor o igual que 0 y si
esto lo multiplicamos por 1 entre 8 1960
esto siempre es mayor o igual que 0 y de
hecho el valor más pequeño que podría
tomar esta expresión es cuando esto es 0
te das cuenta y bueno todo esto es 0 si
x menos 2100 al cuadrado es igual a cero
y esto pasa cuando x menos 2100 es igual
a cero porque ser al cuadrado es cero
por lo que sea es cero así que vamos a
escribirlo y entonces si esto es cero y
ojo solamente estoy hablando de la parte
de naranja quiere decir que x menos 2007
de que se observa vamos a poner de esta
manera esto es igual a cero cuando x
menos 2100 es igual a cero o dicho de
otra manera si yo sumo 2100 de ambos
lados de la ecuación
entonces x tiene que ser igual a 2100
porque date cuenta que será al cuadrado
es cero y cero por lo que sea me da cero
y más aún el valor mínimo que puede
tomar en esta función es decir
de mi parábola es cuando llévale 8 es
decir cuando x vale 2100 y llévale 8
estamos en el vértice de esta parábola
pero entonces habíamos dicho que este
era el valor de x de la mitad de esta
distancia que queríamos por lo tanto la
distancia total es esto por 2 que es
4200 metros
el pilar derecho está a 4 mil 200 metros
del pilar izquierdo quién es la
respuesta de este problema